hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast engineering stem cell
biology or disease modeling and
therapeutics presented by Amir Abdi he's
a perceptual associate at university of
wisconsin-madison
I am Marjorie Torrance of lab foods and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
we are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by
Lavery's laberd's is a leading
scientific social networking website and
producer of educational virtual events
and webinars before we begin I would
like to move mine everyone that this
event is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want any time you want
during the presentation just click on
the green Q&A button located in the
lower left of the presentation window
and type your questions into the box
that appears on the screen well answer
as many questions as you have time for
at the end of the presentation also
please notice that you will be viewing
the presentation in the slide window to
enlarge to the note just click on the
screen icon located on the lower right
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation please click on the
support button at the top right of the
presentation window or use the Q&A
button to let us know that you're having
a problem this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits please click on the
button in the bottom left corner and
follow the process to obtain your
credits please join me in welcoming dr.
Amir Abdeen I will now turn the
presentation over to him
good morning everyone my name is Ahmad
Dean and I'm I'm a postdoctoral
researcher I've been working with
constant medicine today I'll be talking
about engineering stem cell biology or
disease modeling and therapeutic I work
in the energy of the constant Addison
and those constants key to discovery
work in Christina's lab where we work on
engineering of stem cells it's a very
exciting field and I'm going to active
to some of what's happening today so
stem cells they're defined by two key
properties they're multipotent that
means they're able to differentiate into
multiple cell line and they're starting
Ewing so they can propagate in culture
indefinitely and there's kind of two
main categories of stem cells
there's embryonic stem cells and these
are isolated from lattices which is a
stage of embryogenesis and so to get
these embryonic stem cells they're
isolated from this inner cell mass in
the black circle and what's special
about these cells is that the
pluripotent
meaning they can differentiate into
virtually any cell in the body they're
kind of naive cells are from the embryo
and that later differentiate into all
the different cell lines so they can
make skin they can make muscle it can
make neurons one problem with them
though is that there's sometimes ethical
objection
obtaining or using this term so another
cell type that less controversial is
adult stem cells and these exist in a
variety of tissue they are multipotent
so they can differentiate into some
subset of cells in the body where they
act as supporting a pair system so for
example you have stem cells in the blood
which generate new blood cells and help
you know repair injury
gasps come cells in the brain have stem
cells in the gut and you have stem cells
in the skin and one is that you're using
these cells is that you can use them
automatically which means you can get
cells from the patient and then
Transplant them back into the patient's
or for a therapeutic purpose and this is
good because you don't need to find a
match from some another patient and you
can extend these cells Texas evil before
transplanting them back in so these stem
cells there's been lots of advances in
the last few years and people have
figured out lots of very clever ways to
manipulate them to many purposes so I'm
going to go through some stem cell
engineering tools that we use namely if
I'll talk about the programming and
differentiation of stem cells
I'll talk about genomics perturbation or
working with genomes of these stem cells
and then others multiple binding
strategies I'm gonna focus on two that
are particularly relevant for disease
modeling and therapeutics so
reprogramming is actually a very well
straw to be announced in over ten years
but it was a very striking discovery so
people used to think that these
embryonic stem cells whoa it's a one-way
differentiation from the embryonic state
to this differentiate itself
so once the solids differentiate to
specialize implicate fiberglass or skin
so it can go back to this
pluripotent state but what Shinya Menaka
discovered and got a Nobel Prize for
this with that by activating four genes
so up for talks to the era for and
Phoenix was able to get fibroblasts from
in biopsies to turn into what he called
induced pluripotent stem cells
which are cells that are they look like
in rock stem cells they can
differentiate into the three different
serum layers so they can basically
appreciate into all the cells in the
body and you can culture them in vitro
in depth as well and this is great too
it factors are at the cell stores so
when you're allowed you don't have your
embryonic cells anymore right what you
can do is you can get somatic cells
which are ready differentiated and using
the C programming process you can get
very potent stem cells and use either
cell stores for Turkey for example or
for modeling the disease or for
transplantation back so you can take
cells from a patient and trust them come
back into the same patient again
following the need for a match and so
these cells are now becoming a very big
resource that for tissue engineering
another thing is so once you have stem
cells you need to be able to control how
they differentiate so once you have IPS
cells which you can see in the middle
here they can differentiate into on
multiple pathways so depending on which
pathway they go they could end up being
in your arm or they could be like
cardiomyocyte a beating heart cell so
it's very important to be able to
control that control that process and
controlling that is often done by using
guidance from without mental biology
seeing how these embryonic cells in the
embryo develop and are specified in two
different cell types of tissues in the
body and others I am it ends up being
trying to emulate that process as you
can see this example on the right you
can see a part of the spinal column
development and there are different
a new resident pajamas they're the
answers for the hindbrain for the lumbar
part traffic light and so how cells
specify here depends on a host of
different conception practice and by
studying how this development happens
and what kind of practice turned on at
what time people have to have been able
to figure out how to get embryonic stem
cell where a pluripotent stem cell to a
specific lineage that they desire the is
still ongoing but cannot evolve from
very efficient differentiation protocols
to be able to get these stem cell into
the cell type that they need so repoed
on differentiation basically gives us
this very large source of cell that we
can kind of control how they
differentiate and you can make different
tissues or different cell types of
another thing you can do is you can
manipulate the genomics of the soul so
this is not feeling you so even done
this for a while now where you can use
nucleus to make cut in the south so your
DNA and then you can use that cut to
make changes and the DNA sequence of
itself so what people are using before
word is also using is nucleases based on
talking DNA interactions so what that
means is you have these proteins that
can recognize a specific sequence of DNA
and by chaining them together you can
identify some specific point at the DNA
and then they attach a new face doing a
cutting domain and that cutting domain
allows you to and make an edit at the
DNA at the specific point
the problem here is got the engineer a
different protein for every time you
need to target something different so
let's say without proposing to target
one gene but then to target our him you
have to engineer
stop talking again
after you probably heard about CRISPR
which is a recent technology and it's a
so what's really nice about CRISPR cast
9 is it so much easier to design in
these so gasps 9 the advantages it's an
RNA directed RNA guided me PA and what
that means in order to target a specific
sequence of DNA in order to let a single
match but I'd about 20 nucleotides and
what that is is a 20 nucleotide sequence
that's complementary to the DNA so
basically by very simple senses of an
RNA strand that has these 20 nucleotides
coding where you want to target you can
target anywhere so if you have the
sequence for a gene pretty much you can
find with next few days find a guide to
cut the cut there as opposed to weeks or
months and so so far I've just talked
about cutting so what happens after you
cut the DNA so here you see on the left
youngest gasps mine anyways it's guided
by this as you are in a to this spot in
the genome and when it attaches to that
spot it cause a double-stranded break in
the DNA so the DNA strands are pulled
apart
you cut apart and then one of two things
can happen basically you can have the
non-homologous end joining and what that
means is the South tried to repair the
DNA by inserting random places where
nothing happens until super and what
happens there is we get insertions or
deletions of the DNA sequencer which can
mess up the regions that can knock out
the gene or it can cause some change in
how the proteins form from that gene the
problem is this is not a controlled
process so when you induce that cut
it's random basically what happened at
that website so more precise way to add
it should not the bottom which is called
module directed repair and with that we
have targeted sequential placement so
basically in addition to the cast nine
and guide RNA you had the donor DNA
including what you want to insert
advocate there could be a different
sequence it could be a whole new meaning
it could be actually condition you want
corrected or edited and what happens
there is that the cell can actually work
with the template and repair the DNA
according to the template that you give
it effectively giving you the ability to
modify the genome of the soul and that
comes in really handy so CRISPR hasn't
only been used for cutting or modifying
the genome it's been engineered to
there's been lots of engineering going
on other purposes and basically what
they take advantage of is that ochio
cast nine I'm going to lie to the genome
at a specific spot so here in part a
what you see is a adi cast 9 which is
deactivated gas 9 and what that does is
it binds adaptor physics but but it does
not cut the DNA and while not very good
so on its own people have been able to
attend functionalities that he cast 9 to
be able to perform multiple functions at
that spark
for example you can attach a fluorescent
dye so that he cast 9 and be able to
image DNA adduct acidic spot so the find
where sequences inside the cell what you
see in Part B is jeanna in activation so
here you can add a transcriptional
activation which will turn on a gene
calling self-expressive even if it
doesn't usually
and these are helpful for if you want to
attack gene that's not expecting
specific cell type for example you can
also see transcriptional deactivation so
you can turn off the gene without
knocking out the DNA and that's helpful
because again it's mostly a tool for
studying how the cell behaved or the
function of that gene but it could be
also used for in vivo therapeutics with
other functionality this has made
because for a very functional a very
versatile tool in the lab and you can
see the lots of applications for it so
you can either go in from A to B
knockout knocking in trans gene or
different gene you can study knockin at
different spots in the genome this
transcription is affected that way you
can do me to dance the screen so you can
introduce mutations and see whether they
attack the limitations it's so crisp
positions of an adapted for RNA editing
you can use them to edit the RNA in a
Cell again in silencing and activation
and a big component that's gaining
parity is the CRISPR screen where you
can actually encode I darkness for all
the genes and say 20,000 genes in
library and transect that library into a
whole group of cells and by that you can
be kept in Google cells that express so
different cells have different knockouts
and you can do this screen to see if a
specific subset games of some function
to blue screen and have some selection
pressure to see a specific function that
you want and that that's a way to find
in the relevance
and then so in addition to you know
perturbation and reprogramming of cell
Titan appreciation there is also a sub
what I call bind hearing - so these are
tools that in addition to the other two
there so there are many it's very very
broad category but they can be used to
specify and further control how it's all
behave and the need for these to perfect
comes from the complexity in the incipio
environment so on the left on the middle
here you see a sudden its native
environment so it's it has specific
geometry it's in contact with other so
there's a basement membrane so there's
an extracellular matrix
it changes there's movement there's
specific mechanics so in a live system
in vivo itself have a very maybe not
specific but a very defined environment
well when you generally use our culture
I seem to write we generated culture
cells on plastic which is nowhere near
as much control at the same people and
so this makes one of the more important
binding to synthetic scaffolds and with
that we try to recapitulate some of the
properties we see in people in the lab
so we can be able to control this house
in that same way and there's lots of
relevant property so when unique escapa
so hydrogens are prominent examples
because they can have the same kind of
properties like human tissues sometimes
and occupying to these cattle did that
the stiffness for example will attack to
really affect how he'll behave so to
affect how the subscriber cell moves and
it will affect how terms of the crunchy
the composition of the native so what
kind of proteins are outside of dolls
interacting with the circle those
factors
how these silicon presentation is how
these extra cellular components are
presented results rather cryptic sites
or are there it is so able to attach
these moieties or not and to in addition
you can control cell shade help
typography and you can control most of
these factors in a dynamic fashion not
perfectly but it's rapidly improving and
by doing that you can we're able to much
better control cell behavior in a
predictable way so another thing about
the cell that we saw in v2 of that we
usually got yourselves as separate cells
or not as well a new book and that's not
always very helpful
so if welcome to that you can see that
the organization of the body it gets
increasingly complicated with scale we
go from top cellular organization and
then you get sheets of stars for example
and then you get tissue and then you get
organs which are to add levels of
complication I didn't reach the scale
and life sciences so what we're trying
to do is drive all that complexity so
it's all good so going from model
monolayer cell culture we're trying to
do culture thousand steroids and then
we're going to organoid
mediating more complicated but right now
the state of the art is around the
organoid area and how that works is if
you look at the right so looking at
their intestinal organize and looking at
the indian testing you can you can study
that and to account that there is these
intestinal stem cells that we generate a
large part of these villi like
structures in it
and by isolating instances and studying
the their properties people are able to
culture them in vitro in a way that
cause them to make these intestinal
organized you actually have a lot of the
properties in common with the indigent
after the baby and nutrient exchange for
example and what these can be used for
if usually is the modeling of diseases
and then test them or they can be
transplanted back if they are functional
enough that they can call it happy and
again here people who borrow from
development so this is looking at the
brain organ on here and by looking at
the how during development the brain
knows different regions we can model
based on that to try to make different
engines in the lab on a dish and by
further engineering the environment to
induce these regions and different
potential areas for example you can tell
recapitulate how the brain looks in
vitro and this is very useful so going
from single cells to issues there is
very clearly many properties that will
change and improve well and make it more
difficult it's not impossible to predict
what will happen just by studying cells
so here is the organize a very exciting
way to see that complexity in a dish
without having to do individual studies
so they're not so there are caveats so
although you have a near christological
model system and they can be cultured
and there's if you look on the right
dates
there's an organized made for multiple
tissues there's been lung liver stomach
intestines brain organized so these are
all in development
however they are complex and challenging
to culture and they're not they're not
in the complete native environment there
are still differences and there is an
absence of other systems that
interactivity and evil for example the
immune system you know they're present
in the organic culture they're not able
to investing they have information for
example in some of these systems but
they are they doing
so using these tools you can
there's the knowledge improvement in the
ability to model human diseases
especially using patient the right cells
so looking back and trying to get a
bigger picture here we have a patient
having a mutation that's calling a
disease what you can do is you can get
somatic cells for a skin biopsy or blood
biopsy reprogram these cells and get
very potent stem cells from the patient
which we can use to differentiate into
different for example dependency
Dementors Duck Stamp and form alternate
from that so in multiple different organ
and having that disease model it can be
used to study how drugs will interact
with these individuals without acting in
the brain and we can do you can check
for biomarkers that you can need to
detect giving these phenotypes and
finally we can do solid basement
therapies based on this model
perhaps correct a mutation and
transplant back healthy tissue but
modeling human disease is not it's not
it depends on its context dependent so
if you have cells there's only so much
that you can model based on single cell
some of the again the structural
architecture of the tissue might not be
captured there even with organelle it's
some of the tissue interactions or the
more complex interaction may not be
captured however would organize you got
much better in some cases you get much
better control with some of the profiles
you can do you can do large kind of host
microbe interactions you can monitor the
effects of drugs in a structured tissue
for example and you can see the effect
on pee no types that are not you can't
get resolved but shows up take two of
them so that makes modeling using the
patient drugs themselves it's not
suitable for anything right so there are
some criteria that help when selecting
as and use that you'd want to model
patient rights council so the
inheritance is based on a single gene
it's easier to model them some polygenic
penetrance which means the disease has
high patterns it would mean if you have
the he our spirit intention you have the
needy
well you have no conscience the relation
is not that period of presentation and
not have to be or have it so it's not a
clear duration in genetics and
developmental disorders are easier
tomorrow then late onset one because in
each of the system and it's up it's
optimal to do this when you don't have a
suitable animal model so if you have a
good model it might not be very useful
to try patient arrived and again simpler
phenotypes are easier to study and
excessive differentiation that efficient
and well controlled here would be better
if you I'll give an example that we've
been working on which is death penalty
and that's the generative eye disease
and don't watch chicken can't see the
lesions in the retina and I seen with
the disease and the weapon is kind of a
simulation of someone who might have
that it is how their vision might look
and this is a disease of the RPE layer
at the back of the eye box right here
and our peeler is the RPE layers the
retinal pigment epithelium and there are
some pigment epithelium is this layer at
the back of the eye that supports the
photoreceptors in the retina and one of
its main functions is recycle byproducts
from the retina and when it fails to do
that they start to become degeneration
internationally and in vision and this
is disease in a known gene the best one
gene which encodes for the spoken one
and the second one as you can see on the
right is this transmembrane
calcium-activated chloride channel and
so this is actually by calcium and
chloride channel and mutations in the
gene can cause so it's so avoid some
imaginary diseases in the single gene
there are other advantages to tell you
the gene using a stem cell model they
serve disease and this is important
because large diseases such as cancer
you can use in Big Data approaches where
you can look at thousands of patients
look at gene wide Association studies
and try to tell which genes are common
for specific symptoms of diseases and do
it that way however food diseases are
rare it's hard to it's hard to use that
same approach with a few samples so here
it becomes important to be able to to
really control the model using to be
able to get useful data and sober to
best took an opposite also has
mechanistic swatches other Dracula and
it's interesting in Egypt because so
what you're looking at on the left in
the slide is amino acid sequence of the
protein and colored colored residues
represent you take disease-causing
mutations and you can see different
mutations will cause different Palatino
types and depending of whether your
mutation is in the calcium class or the
chlorine binding for ID binding area
contain the disease can have different
maybe not the untyped defense mechanisms
and so this makes it important to
actually study not not just the gene but
specific mutation making it also really
convenient to be able to introduce
orientations and people have been using
this so they've figured out ways to make
RPE layers retinal pigment appear in
layers so much to organize in in vitro
and these layers are actually the
closest thing to the human model so
they're even closer than mouse model and
you can show their IPs so I guess either
right right right from human iPS cells
and what you can use these is you can
study the effects of drugs so on the
right you're seeing a study where one of
the jobs of the RP layer is to recycle
photoreceptor outer segments but when
you have a D type these photos dr. outer
segments accumulate causing a generation
and so what you can use these models for
you can study the effect of that for
example so some drugs may well cost
irritation but they may not work for
others and that gives it personalized
medicine screening dimension where you
can take the specific patient
study the interaction of drugs for this
patient and hopefully get a more
specific idea of which trucks to you on
a patient patient basis so this is
already pretty complicated but I wanted
to see what you can do with other so
other diseases that are not known
engineering so here I talk about I'll
talk about Parkinson's disease and two
main mutations or genes involved in
Parkinson's disease
it's a loose enriched repeat kinase to
alaric taking shown in that here and
sign nuclear SNC a shown in orange here
and if you get patients with positive
disease and get start from them
reprogram them say I'm if I PST or in
historical stem cells from a patient's
what you can do is you can using CRISPR
or some interesting method you need or
correct mutation in one of the genes and
what this tells you is how much of the
phenotype is caused by the specific
intention and then you could get
themselves original source again and
crank the other one and again ask how
much of the phenotype is modulated by
that mutation however this doesn't
really capture
synergist synergistic effects so to
speak especially at their developmental
so here what we could be able to do is
what I help individual kept healthy
cells that don't have the partners in
skin type and introducing mutations and
by the invitation and one gene or the
other in you can add presentation alone
what's the effect of this addiction
alone and then by combining them income
even combine them in different sequences
you can study the synergistic effects
that they have together again it gets
pretty complicated pretty fast
especially with the use of have multiple
in patients and so it's not only whether
this mutation causes this or that they
can cause of that so for poisoning
disorders you have these different modes
that could happen it could be that
permutation called something another
mutation called something if you
different which is depicted on top here
well it could be that mutations at
different time points or different
stages accumulate to causing phenotype
which would be again a harder model
harder thing tomorrow but it's not just
proportion in this order so even for
monogenic disorders where you have one
gene there it's not as clear as just
beaming the mutation and seeing if the
head coach or not so for example here on
the left you can see a patient a and we
study one mutation that might be causing
a phenotype and you could correct that
and see what happens to a phenotypic
trait and let's say we see a reduction
as we see here for that purple bar but
then you get a patient B in green and
they should be we do the exact same
thing with correct imitation but this
change is not it's there but it's not as
profound
so here it's not just the effect of the
gene it's just there's an influence of
the background genetics with the
epigenetics or it could be a lifestyle
based effect so it's not always that
here how the interactions happen and on
the right so what if you also try to use
the disease into into wild type cell
patient a you had less severe symptoms
of Dracula he might get in that mutation
and introducing it into a control line
might cause arm or a harsher effect then
getting patient needs medication
although patient we have multi variable
and again that has to do with the back
down genetics or how so the mounting is
not very straightforward but it's a very
useful tool to be able to tell they
influence our gene in a much more
sophisticated way than people will do is
just single cell or a patient drive so
that if you edit the genes the few
specific mutations or to control three
the correct patient cell lines or
introduced disease and control cell
lines
it's very helpful mechanistic to in
addition screening what you can also do
with these cells is a therapeutic kind
of direction and stem cells have not put
punches that make them suitable for
therapeutic use so here are given again
to everything from stem cells which are
found in the bone marrow they found in
adipose tissue but these cells have
multiple effects so they have
dragon attacks they are part in attacks
which were by the secrete growth factors
for example that help Andrew Johnson so
they they're frequently used for that
purpose where they injected donate bucks
to talk for example and they stimulate
angiogenesis in the affected area they
have immune modulator tax right which
helped populate the immune system which
can be desirable in some cases and so
the injection stem cells they can
differentiate down variable pathways so
they can differentiate into adipocytes
which are capsules contra sites in
cartilage and they can differentiate
into active sites or bone tissue
basically and if by trying to control
the differentiation they're being tested
for transplantation for desire to
diseases which cause tissue and actually
there's several clinical trials using
enzyme from stem cells and as you can
see there in a bunch of you so they're
in bone and calculated diseases
neurological diseases and cardiovascular
diseases make up the bulk of Vancouver's
Varanasi very are they and further
enumerative those properties are also so
really being able to make use of these
cells controlling them makes this large
space where you can use them for
different therapeutic purposes and the
natural makeup stem cells is so they're
adult stem cells there's no ethical
concerns really you can expand them
axial and transplanting them there are
tourists so you don't you
don't know if other daughters however
IPS is why they have some other
disadvantage there are they're also
they're also currently intent to
transfer several diseases the actual
being just minding the eye for
age-related macular degeneration this is
actually our PA layers after dr. Alton
and I and they make the layers and they
transplanted into the eye dopaminergic
neurons are made for from IPS series for
Parkinson's disease being tested for
spinal cord injury to making I'll start
for diabetes and for infarctions so I
can see drive Kagamine sites right now
so to summarize Alba convinced you that
stem cells the other embryonic induced
pluripotent stem cells a valuable
resource for both modeling of diseases
and therapeutic purposes that leads you
to differentiate the cells reprogram
somatic cells into these three forces
themselves editor jeans or modulate the
genome and combined with other battery
strategies can be used to so we can
control the stem cell or we track where
the process of controlling some dog
behavior the genotype aspect of the
phenotype as well to show the structural
organization and so right now stem cell
disease models and thirties they're
advancing rapidly and there's multiple
therapies in clinical trials currently
and this is actually called attention of
the APA which has designated by
regenerative medicine advanced therapies
originated at 9:30 designation or an
accelerated clinical testing and trial
process and with this I'd like to thank
you
and big inflection thank you doctor
American that informative presentation
we will now start the live Q&A portion
of the webinar if you have a question
you'd like to ask please do so now just
click on the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
type your question into the box that
appears on your screen and click on the
send button well answer as many of your
questions as we have time for let's get
started
our first question is can gene editing
eliminate genetic diseases composed of
single mutations
well this is a complicated question
because well theoretically gene acting
does so if you correct a mutation it's
no longer there in here it's a very
complicated question so let's say you
have a genetic disease in specific organ
right now we're not able to correct it
mutation so if you put in the cat man
and right here you're not gonna be able
to correct it in all the cells in a
subset of the South and whether that
helps or not it's very dependent on the
system in question so for sickle cell
anemia example if you try to ollie the
stem cells that make mutated red blood
cells so this mutation causes us to be
not able to efficiently carry oxygen
causing that anemic type if you try to
target the stem cells forming the
phenotype and you correct the mutation
in a subset of them a subset of their
red blood cells kept on normally and
that will give a phenotypic improvement
maybe not a complete improvement but
people are seeing improvement in this
disease in mice however if you think
about a lot mental disease for example
security teams after some of the attacks
have happened you may not be able to
reverse that one thing that's people are
excited about right now germline editing
or anything in the embryo stage where
all the sudden WD edit would be
corrected for example however it's not
clear if that can be done efficiently
right now and there are ethical concerns
thank you for that answer
our next question is are there safety
concerns from errant differentiation of
quarry protein stem cells once
transplanted yes so actually the very
important stem cells to differentiate
conductor in this kind of application so
it's it is a safety concern because stem
cells will form teratomas in mice one
implanted and that's just goes like and
brandon differentiation of the stem
cells it's not very safe so typically
what people do is try to use the stem
cells ex-vivo take this out or equally
on them and then form a differentiated
cell type and just on that back in so
you don't come the possibility of
education and they're usually very
stringent selection and quality control
that needs to go into
ex-vivo processing before
transplantation back to body to them i
would like to once again thank dr.
europeans presentation i would also like
to thank my cleats for making today
educational web cats possible before we
go i want to let everyone know that
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through December of
2017 you will receive an email from lab
roots letting you know when this webcast
will be available at the replay please
share that announcements with your
colleagues who might have this today's
live event that's all for now thank you
for joining us and we hope to see you
again soon goodbye